now ask that you join us for a moment of
silence for all those who have fallen
due to the ongoing covet 19 pandemic
along with the lives lost due to racial
injustice
crawford boxes surrounded by cardboard
cutouts astros absolutely dominated the
seattle mariners a year ago as kyle
seeger stands in with
two away pulls that one over to the
right side julie on a couple of hops
tosses it over to verlander and
that will retire the side for marco
gonzalez looking for his first career
win against the astros over 200 innings
for him last year 147 strikeouts total
here is one tough hombre here alex
bregman here's the stretch and the pitch
fast ball swing and a fly ball into
right field toward the line in shallow
on the run is malik smith he's there in
fair territory makes the catch and
that'll retire the side here's kyle
lewis he was a hitting star at summer
camp here in seattle 10 for 23 four
homers seven runs batted in oh boy that
boss tank that's gone see you later
you can tell by this sound giddy up and
gone one nothing mariners we're
thousands of miles away
and you knew that sucker was way out of
here
he's a long way away yeah yeah d gordon
making his way into the stance there you
go
that that's uh pretty crazy right there
will
turn the order over to the top of the
order shed long junior here's the one
two
and that is strike three called got him
looking as verlander prances back to the
dugout a one two three inning he's got
four punch outs our team maldonado with
a runner at third and josh reddick won
out trying to tie this thing up
that one ripped into left field and the
astros were on the board
that'll tie it at one martine maldonado
found one to hit he didn't miss it so
the mariners won the astros one here in
the top half of the fourth that'll bring
up third baseman kyle seeger here's the
pitch of the way swinging a high drive
deep into right field reddit going back
looking up and goodbye baseball about
four rows back into the lower deck and
right field
kyle seeger loves hitting here at
mid-may park he gives the mariners a 2-1
lead over verlander nola slide out to
left-center
his first time up the 2-2 to nola swing
and a miss got him on a slider and that
is verlander's six strikeout one away
now we have jose altuve batting with two
runners in scoring position
the o2
breaking ball grounded left side deep in
the hole backhanded by crawford throws
to first and it's not in time diaz
scores maldonado goes to third and we're
tied at two
and that's gonna do it for marco
gonzalez here in the fifth inning
seattle mariners having to go to the
bullpen it is zach rhodes this one into
right field
and that's
dropped in right now tuvay will make it
into second base and that'll give the
astros their first lead of the night
michael brantley steps in one for two
the 2-1
and brantley drives this deep to right
field and sends back smith still going
back looking up see you later
a three-run home run for michael
brantley and the astros lead in 6-2
boy how things turned so quickly they
garnered a four run lead unbelievable
how things turn kyle seger with the solo
home run in the fourth
on the ground to break but for one
correa over to julie for two the double
play set him up that was nice team
maldonado has had some great swings
tonight
maldonado hits this one into right it'll
dump down in front of malik smith here's
a throw to the plate cut off and toro
will score martine maldonado his second
run bat at end of the night the astros
extend the lead to seven to two well
justin verlander's night is over chris
stavinsky makes his way to the mound
there it is that's cod to get the swing
over the top for the strikeout daniel
vogelback is over two
there's a swing and a miss
vogelback goes down swinging jose
marmalejos is over for two three balls
two strikes two outs to the swing and a
miss and he strikes out the side so devo
gets it done in the seventh inning
here's carlos correa 0-4-3
gray is looking for his first one and he
pops this one sky-high down the left
field line right along the line
and the left fielder can't see it and
that's going to land in the outfield
they're going to send guriel home and
he's going to score on the double for
correa
vermillios in left field couldn't find
it that hit the roof
did it hit the roof and hit the roof in
fair territory which means it's a live
ball and so that was the difficulty
marmaleo's had if it hits in foul
territory it's a dead ball but that
actually hit in fair territory it was a
sky-high ball nolan
makes his major league debut
that one hit
high and deep to left field brantley is
there on the track makes the catch and
there's one away in the ninth
four spring training games through four
scoreless innings that one hit to altoo
in the line drive is
jose altuve time to jump perfectly and
there's two away in the ninth nola
paredes trying to finish it here
that went on the ground correa should do
it
and that's the ball game
and the astros pick up
win number one on opening day in 2020
[Music]